la región de uttar a kan en india desde
el domingo los equipos de rescate no
dejaron de trabajar buscando en los
escombros excavando todos los métodos
son buenos para salvar una vida tras la
catástrofe hasta ahora hemos avanzado un
poco y el túnel no se ha abierto todavía
se han recuperado 26 cuerpos y las
operaciones de rescate están en marcha
señor cuál es el plan para hoy hoy
esperamos poder abrir el túnel por la
tarde
alrededor de 200 personas siguen
desaparecidas después de que parte de un
remoto glaciar del himalaya se
desprendiera el domingo destruyendo
puentes rompiendo presas y enviando un
torrente de agua rocas y escombros por
un valle unas imágenes difundidas por la
televisión local mostraban a un hombre
que salía de un túnel del proyecto
hidroeléctrico en construcción las
brigadas de rescate se han centrado en
perforar el túnel de 25 kilómetros de
longitud para alcanzar los posibles
sobrevivientes aquí tenemos una
estrategia en la que podemos trabajar
con dos máquinas allí se está trabajando
en ello para que puedan ser rescatadas
pronto estamos tratando de llegar a las
30 a 35 personas que sospechamos están
atrapadas en el túnel habitan
los expertos creen que las fuertes
nevadas seguidas por jornadas soleadas
provocaron un derretimiento que dio
origen a la avalancha grupos
ambientalistas señalan la construcción
de hidroeléctricas en esta zona
montañosa como la responsable por el
desastre ahora también está en tela de
juicio la solidez de las presas que en
teoría deberían poder soportar torrentes
de esta magnitud